ملفنا الاول اليوم مالي بامتياز ونبدا
بالتحديد من جيوب المواطنين العرب الجيوب
التي صارت تفرغ من محتواها قبل ايام من
نهايه الشهر الراتب الشهري في سبع دول
العربيه لم يعد كافيا ليقضي حاجات
المواطنين وطبعا هذه الدول تعاني من
الغلاء مع ضعف في الاجور لبنان العراق مصر
تونس المغرب الجزائر الاردن دول يعاني
مواطنوها من ضعف الرواتب الشهريه وعدم
كفايتها بحسب استطلاع اجراه موقع ارم
الاماراتي هذه الازمه تلقي بظلالها على
واقع الحال في هذه الدول لتزيد المعاناه
المعيشيه خصوصا مع ارتفاع مستمر للاسعار
فيها المزيد مع علاء سرحان
او لميس
سبع دول عربيه يعاني مواطنها من ضعف
مرتباتهم بالمقارنه بحجم المصاريف بحسب
استطلاع ارام 94% من مواطنين الدول السبع
يصرفون دخلهم قبل نهايه الشهر باسبوع 92%
من المشاركين بالاستطلاع من مصر يفقدون
دخلهم قبل نهايه الشهر اكثر من 35% من
المشاركين بالاستطلاع في الجزائر ينفذ
دخلهم نهايه الاسبوع الاول من كل شهر سته
وثلا. من المشاركين بالاستطلاع من المغرب
ينفتح دخلهم في نهايه الاسبوع الثاني من
الشهر و 48 من المشاركين بالدراسه يعيلون
من ثلاث الى خمس افراد في تونس 70% من
المشاركين بدراسه من لبنان يعينون اكثر من
خمسه افراد ايضا على كل حال سالنا الناس
في الاردن ما الذي يستهلك اكبر جزء من
راتبك الشهري يتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
اكثر شيء راتب بروح على الكهرباء وعلى
المياه اكثر اشي وعلى المدارس مصروف
المدارس والكهرباء يعني اكثر جزء بستهلكن
من الراتب بروح على ايجار البيت يعني
فعليا المواطن الاردني المستاجر يحتاج الى
راتبين اللي هم راتب يكون اجارته راتب
يصرف على حاله اما اللي عايش على راتب
واحد وبيته اجار فعليا دائما ملحوق
ومقضيها دين بدين على اقساط الجامعه
الدراسه بشكل عام يعني
والاشياء الثانيه هي مصاريفها طبيعي
والله اكبر جزء من راتبي بروح على اجره
البيت والكهرباء والماء والمواصلات هسه
يعني على وضع البلد الاقتصادي حاليا اكبر
جزء بيروح اكيد للايجار البيت يعني
بالنسبه للوضع اللي بنعيشه بالبلد اللي هي
الكهرباء بتاخد اكثر صنف يعني خلينا نحكي
وايجار البيت
[موسيقى]
تنظمي الينا الخبير الاقتصاديه ندى لا في
نادي يسعد صباحك العربيه الدراسه تقول انه
الراتب سبع دول عربيه للمواطنين لم يعد
يكفي نود ان نسمع منك نصائح كيف نحدد
ميزانيه راتبنا او مدخولنا الشعري اوكي
اول شيء بدنا نوافق انه ما حدا عم بحس انه
راتبه بكفيه سواء هون بدول الخليج او بلاد
يعني مثل الاردن سوريا الجزائر ولا اي حدا
حتى باوروبا ما منحس ان الراتب بكفي هاي
اسباب انه في عنا القوه الشرائيه ما عادت
زي قبل كل شيء عم يغلى فما عم بنحس ان
الراتب عم بكفي وكمان كل ما الراتب علي عم
بيتغير لحتى يتناسب مع علو الراتب فما
منحس انه الراتب بكفي كيف ممكن انه احنا
نستفيد نستخدم راتبنا قبل ما نحس انه خلص
قبل نهايه الشهر اول شيء انا بدي اكون
عارفه من وين جاييني امكم كل تبعتي بدي
اكون انا عندي فكره عن الرقم المتوقع راح
احصل عليه بنهايه الشهر بعدين راح اقسم
الشغلات ثابته مثل الاجار البيت مدارس
الاولاد الكهرباء الشغلات الاساسيه وبعدين
عنا الشغلات الفرعيه او مش كثير مهمه مثل
يعني في عنا بالانجليزي اشي اسمه اللي هو
مثل ما قلنا هلا الايجار الكهرباء
الضروريات بعدين عنا
اللي حتى انا استخدمه
بالاسمنت
طيب ندى اليوم كتير من الناس بروحوا لفكره
الاستثمار مثلا كل ما بيجي راتب خليني
استثمر بذهب هلا عم بيستثمروا بالبيتكوين
وغيره هل بتنصحه انه نستفيد بجزء من
الراتب بهذا الموضوع اكيد اكيد يعني بدل
ما انا اخلي الراتب عندي قاعد او انا بس
حاططته بالبنك او حاططته عندي بالكاش ليش
ما انا استثمر فيه وازيد من هذا الراتب
سواء مثل ما قلت او البيتكوين كريبتو او
حتى بشركه صغيره فايا كان ممكن انا انمي
في الراتب ليه لا يعني ممكن انه يزيد من
طيب ندى 30% للتوفير لماذا يعجز غالبيه
الناس على ادخار 30% من راتبهم
مثل ما قلنا في ناس ما بتقدر تعمل البلانك
من قبل بوقت يعني انا قبل بوقت بدي اكون
انا عارفه انه انا جاييني هالقد بدي اقسم
مثلا انه اوكي انا بعرف راح اخذ هذا
المبلغ رح اخلي قبل مثلا انا بدي اسافر
بعد خمس شهور ممكن اني انا اغير الثري
لانه انا مقرره من قبل بوقت انه انا رح
اسافر فاولا بحجز التذكره قبل بوقت بطلع
لي ارخص عملت كل قبل بوقت فكل ما انا عملت
قبل بوقت وقسمت ماي غولز شورت تيرمز راح
يكون كثير اسهل لك لبعدين طيب ندى اليوم
ليه كل ما بيزيد الراتب بضل يستمر النفاذ
متل ما قلت لك اللايف ستايل بيتغير يعني
اذا انا معوده حالي 15,000 تكفيني صار
راتبي 40 انا لابسه تاعي راح يتغير لحتى
يتناسب مع هذا العلوفه بغير كافي طيب ندى
سالنا الناس في العراق ما الذي يستهلك
اكبر جزء من راتبك نشوف ونرجع لك
الراتب يعني بصراحه يعني هو عندي انا
كليات وعندي بنات اثنين همين مدارس اهليه
ويبقى شيء قليل شيء بسيط يعني مال وقود
سياره
مصرف شخصي والباقي البيت والايجار البيت
[موسيقى]
اكمل فوقه عندي عندي بنيه بالمحل
ياخذون من يجيب لهم ماكو تروح
ماكو ما تدفع والله يروح للخطوط المدارس
للمعيشه والله اكثر شيء
يعني مرات التدريب المدارس خطوط مدارس وها
المصاريف الباقيه
[موسيقى]
طيب سمعنا سؤال الناس بس اليوم ندى كمان
في شغله انه في كتير ناس بتاخد قرود وهذا
جزء كبير من نفاد الراتب هل بتنصحوا
كخبراء اقتصاديين انه الانسان يحاول يوفر
مصاري لبعد اربع سنين يستفيد من هذا
المبلغ الكبير ولا لا يختصر وقت ويختصر
سنين وياخذ القرض ولو مع نفاذ الراتب لا
اكيد نتجنب القرود قدر الامكان يعني ليه
انا ازيد على حالي فوائد غير ما كانت
بالحسبان من القول انا عملته قبل يعني في
ناس بتضطر انها ما استلمتها تجيب سياره
تشتري بيت بس يعني نحاول قد ما بنقدر انه
نغطي هذا المبلغ بالكاش
طيب بالنسبه للناس اللي عندها دين ندى كيف
يمكن تتصرف مع الدين بنرتبها الشهري مثل
ما قلنا ممكن تستخدم لتسديد الدين بس
الشغلات حتى ممكن انه احنا نعمل كت للون
يعني ما في داعي انه انا
عندي شغله مستخدمه منيحه فانا ممكن اني ما
في داعي انه انا اجيب جديد دايما خاصه
للناس بدهم يسدوا دين او يعملوا اكثر ممكن
انه يعني طيب اذا بدنا نحكي بالدولار لانه
اذا كل يعني معظم الدول العربيه عم بشكي
مواطنينها انه الراتب قليل وعم ينفد اذا
بدنا نحكي بالدولار قديه لازم يكون معدل
راتب بالشخص مع لايف ستايل عايش حياته هون
بالبلد أني بالمنطقه نقول يعني 4000 دولار
المفروض يكون الواحد قادر طبعا بيختلف اذا
كان الواحد عنده عيله رب اسره معين لعائله
كامله بيختلف بس الابراج ممكن نحكي من
اربع ل 5000 دولار شكرا جزيلا لكن في
الاستوديو اقتصاديه شكرا ندى